[Musik]
auf und davon präsentiert von
[Applaus]
[Musik]
Edelweiß fahr muss probieren der Papa
macht un
mlich
viel Platz für Action und noch mehr Spaß
direkt vor der
[Applaus]
[Musik]
Haustüre Raudi ja wie
du aber wenn immer das darf nicht
nachher könen Sie sich nicht so
Entwickler seit einem Monat wohnt
Familie charna in Ihrem Traumhaus in
schopy die Rheintaler sind an der
Westküste Floridas
angekommen mit einem Mobile Home ihrem
ersten Objekt wollen sie ins
immobilienbsiness
einsteigen es ist ungewohnt kalt im
Sonnenstaat Florida und die Heizung ist
ausgefallen hier ah jetzt
brennt auf und davon in die Einsamkeit
Islands hier gibt es Ruhe Raum und vor
allem viel Platz ein Grundstück so groß
wie 600 Fußballfelder gehört hier zwei
Innerschweizern Isabel und steef Felix
Mech alles
lang bald schon sollen hier tiny Häuser
für Gäste
entstehen
genau muss es ja den sie wenn den
wirklich Fundament machen das muss den
wirklich das muss
stimmenpanis gemacht auf Isländisch ein
Restaurant auf Mallorca OT hat alles in
diesen Traum investiert mit Gabor seinem
Partner gestaltet er das Lokal
um zur Unterstützung Reisen Freunde aus
der
Schweiz die bisherige Besiter hilft mit
dabei entstehen Missverständnisse vorne
die ich
mitst du mit habe ich gerade dreimal
gesagt die kommen auf dem Balkon wenn
muss machen D muss vorwärts
machen weil schon ist Eröffnung und
diese soll gelingen wir dieses besten
uns persönlichen bin sehr offen so
lustig und das ich meine in der Schweiz
hat das Leute sehr gerne
gehabt
[Musik]
auf Island ist der Spätsommer
angebrochen mit der Ruhe ist es nun
vorbei aus der Schweiz sind drei
Container angeliefert worden ihr Inhalt
Bauelemente für drei tiny
Häuser auch aus der Schweiz angereist
ist Zimmermann he
fr
sokommenkommen
hallo
super
jaall B Mannschaft ist tagszuvor mit dem
Flieger
angekommen so sieh gut
a ihr Ziel in dii Wochen sollen drei
Häuser
stehen wochenlang haben Steff und Isabel
die Fundamente für die Häuser
gelegt 45 Kubik Beton verbaut und
hunderte met Strom und Wasserleitungen
gelegt eine knochenharte Arbeit selbst
für ste den gelernten
Steinmetz es ist schon
krampaufma und ich noch nicht so und das
Woch TR optimal und das ist jetzt
wirklich Woche der letemischt vor wir
jetzt Aufbau und es ist knappen
[Musik]
aber wo hinter H eiglich t got alles t
ja das ist doch gut das ges sehr stabil
aus das kommt gut jetzt s wir da schon
ausesse Winkel aus vorbereit dass wir
den mor morgen nachher
einfach Kran da
setz ihre ferienlodge verfügt bereits
über drei kleine Wohnungen eine davon
heißt himmin der
Himmel
hsch
h
hoffentlich
sie hoffen wir schon
ja
au du kanst das machen da ja gut
ha
ja einfach
aber die meist sowieso wahscheinlich und
da war einfach Zimmer wunderbar aus DAO
ja W F einfach mer vi mit Wasser ist
wahrscheinlich Problem du lachst jetzt
aber letzt Jahr hab Problem mit dem
Wasser ja Sommer ist war ja und H kein
Wasser mit
also da wahslichch boriger machen dass
man noch Wasser mit B
ja mit der Erweiterung ihrer lot werden
sie noch mehr Wasser brauchen auf Island
ist jeder Hof selbst dafür
verantwortlich Eigenständigkeit und
weite das haben die Schweizer gesucht
ihr nächster Nachbar lebt einen
Kilometer weit entfernt trotzdem oder
vielleicht gerade deswegen sind die
beiden schnell Teil der lokalen
Gemeinschaft
geworden
[Musik]
mir h jetzt da die 100 lü wo da hinten
im Tal
WN für und die 100 l schon rech die
Family also da weiß jeder jedes über
jede und facebook weiß so alles jeder
postet alles D und ich
glbch im
schieß wenn du hilf brauch und da
frag morgen S
in 24 Stunden schon soll nämlich das
erstetinus aufgerichtet sein
gut
so paar Sachen
wichtig
machen
Container du gerade was W
drin Sam im Container das musf relativ
schwierig das nicht kaputt geht mit
die
montier schn h dass mit die richtige F
der packen wir
[Musik]
mor
das brisas Delmar zu deutsch die
Meeresbrise das ist
ma gempelis Restaurant wochenlang haben
sie es umgebaut morgen endlich ist die
Eröffnung gabors ehemalige Chefin ist
samtfreund zur Unterstützung auf die
Insel
gereist ich bin gespannt vor allem l das
das nimmt mir Wunder ja wir m aber zer
fertig werden
gut
ja langsam steigt die
Nervosität nur wenige Minuten vom Lokal
entfernt ist das Meer Gabo balock kommt
ursprünglich aus Ungarn er hat schon in
London und in der Schweiz gelebt das war
immer
meine meine träum irgendwo zu leben wo
gibt mehr weißt du wie soll ich sagen in
Ungarn
leider dort ist nicht so ich meine dort
haben wir nicht so viel Chance zu mer
sehen und das habe ich nie gedacht dass
ich werde mein Leben
erleben an der Gala aguya findet er Sand
für die
Windlichter zum Glück hat nur eine beste
nicht
zweimal so
h alles
gut Flug meine
Hand
rot Schnitzel vom Schweinerücken das ist
der
Maran kocht seit Jahren schon in bras
ist froh dass er ihn behalten
konnte aber auch der erfahrene Koch ist
ein wenig
nervös alle sind im Schuss besonders gab
ist voller Tatendrang und dann
passiert zeig mal Gabor ist gegen die
frisch geputzte Scheibe
gerannt ihr habt die Aufkleber von dem
Fenster abgemacht an dem Fenster da
waren überall Aufkleber was für
Aufkleber da waren Aufkleber willkommen
und so weiter diese Aufkleber sind nicht
nur da weil die schön sind die sind da
weil das Pflicht ist Aufkleber auf
Fenster zu haben so soas nicht passiert
KT ihr das hier
mit wir brauchen Aufkleber und brauchen
Kinderschutz D keine
Kinder so ist gut
ist gut Schatz
mhm cororina sorry was ist los was ist
los mit deine kommst Du hier und machst
W nein es sind einfach Sachen ja aber
dann kannst du es mit mir normal
besprechen ja ich mir ist jetzt
aufgefallen
dasster hab Pass ja ja und jetzt hat er
sich weh getan ja aber dann musst du
nicht so kommen sorry habe ich keine
Lust für das ich ja Nein ne du hier
sollten Tische stehen bleiben weil die
Gäste Hochsitzen wollen machst du ich
habe gesagt das ist eine Uhr das ist
basiskenmfnis für Restaurant und Bar
dass man keine Uhr hinter der Theke hat
um die Leute daran zu erinnern wie spät
es ist machst du trotzdem ihr macht
alles wie ihr wollt ist ja auch gut ist
na ja euer Laden ja das können wir doch
normal besprechen normal ja normal ja
nachdem m Leute
verletzen
super alles sch
[Musik]
gesag der Golf von Mexico liegt gut 10
Minuten von charnas neuem daheim
entfernt in Florida ist es Winter und
die Nächte sind bitter kalt so kalt war
es während der letzten 30 Jahre
nicht trotz der Kälte ihr neues
Familienmitglied Hund Rocky muss raus
Mario wollte schon immer einen Hund
haben hier hat er endlich Zeit
dafür vor z Woch
Tierheim
Rocky und
ich er so so bez von der erste Minute
ist in
Pum und und FM geschlaf also
W schon immer zu
gehört einmal mehr auch in Ihrem
Traumhaus macht die Heizung
Probleme in Florida heizt man mit der
Klimaanlage
das S also sor tut gut aber so
unter plus frü da
immer verdammt
frch ja warm kalt oder und der stellt
nicht selber ab
alsokt
verpasstüh nachher kürz Hüte innerhalb
von 10 Minuten ab auf 10°
inwendig die Nächte sind wohl kalt doch
kaum zeigt sich die Sonne wird es im
namhaften sonnenstart schnell
warm wieder warm werden okay bin ich
froh jetzt ma wieder noch
[Musik]
gutt und ja nervt so in schichterleit
und zi den eine nach der andere ab
Lauf Morgen hat Lil Rose ihren ersten
Schultag mit großer Begeisterung
besuchte sie in der Schweiz die erste
Klasse doch nur sie Wochen lang dann ist
die Familie
ausgewandert
duammelt in der schwitz
ja
Rucksack ke Rucksack
mitnehmen W nicht wir nehmen aufed Fall
Rucksack
mit
blätteresmelt alles muss perfekt ja ich
das
nicht Lily Rose steht vor einem neuen
Lebensabschnitt und die ganze Familie
fiebert
[Musik]
mit auf Island haben die Zimmerleute ein
Ziel heute soll das erste tiny houseus
stehen Element für Element verlässt den
Container got eig richtig los
ja das ich
nochal kaum angefangen und schon kommt
die erste Bodenplatte perfekt auf stes
Fundament zu
liegen
mus gleichzeitig läuft der
Gästebetrieb
also nein nach den richtig AK od oder
was ist
den ein Ehepaar hat für eine Nacht eine
Wohnung gebucht jetzt ist die Hang Lodge
voll aus 55 Bauelementen setzen die
Arbeiter ein Häuschen zusammen der Bau
kommt gut
voran
öum bra nicht und
schla
und jzigen apartmen
sleer
[Musik]
ein riesiges Bauprojekt auf Island
manchmal kann es Isabel kaum fassen
wohin sie das Leben verschlagen
hat
das schon extrem speziell
und ja wirklich
fre D man wirklich alles auf Termin
bracht und das wirklich alles
funktioniert und D es lauft nein wir
sind wir
sinded
und es versteht sich von selbst die
Arbeiter werden verpflegt das ist
aufwendig und muss gut geplant sein
es lohnt sich für nicht wir fahren halb
Stund bis zum nächsten ich aufs lad und
wenn wir den nurw Brot schnell halb also
Stund fah rech ist das natürlich
[Musik]
dannigentlichberelramprampramp
der kleine Zwischenfall auf Mallorca hat
für viel Aufregung gesorgt gut dass die
Zeit fehlt um sich lange zu ärgern kann
morgen schon
reservieren ja er würde gerne für morgen
reservieren na wie geht's mir gut dir
auch ja mir auch wie viel wollt kommen
15 Leute wie spät woll kommen 19 Uhr
kriegen wir das hin ja ja kochagt ja wir
sehen uns morgen
tschüss es hat eine Aussprache gegeben
und diese wird nun mit einem Essen
gefeiert sowieso Gabor ist
glücklicherweise mit einem kleinen
Schrecken davon
gekommen ich fühle mich nicht mehr so
ausgeschwollen aber hier
ja das kann man
passieren ich habe mich heute einfach
nur erschreckt ich denke nein nicht ein
Arbeitsunfall schon vor wir aufmachen
also das habe ich einfach ein Schreck
bekommen und da habe ich dann einfach
kurz reagiert so warum aber
gut ja beide W eigentlich wirklich nur
das Beste für es geschafft und das haben
wir zeigich mit diesem Gespräch so
besegl und das B so auf mit all Sache
wir haben eigent jetzt auch für
persönlich auch das eigentlich
gelöst ja danke für mal ja ma
ich morgen geht es
los so ist
[Musik]
fertig die Stimmung soll fröhlich
sein sch dir
kartoffelsal danke für alles Gute Start
für ja komm jetzt alle
[Musik]
mitein
wier auch in Florida herrscht große
Vorfreude mussch
endlich ist es soweit der erste Schultag
im großen
[Musik]
Amerika schon vor ihrer Auswanderung
haben sich die Eltern viel Zeit genommen
um eine gute Schule für die kleine zu
finden speziell da
alles ist anders System ist total
anders Schu sind komplett andersbaut in
der
schwizp Kindergarten nach die Klass
schfangen s schön eigentlich rumgelaufen
da wie es funktioniert schon
diep
mir s
tschüss Lil Rose weiß die ganze Familie
unterstützt
sie das gibt
Sicherheit se nachher wieder Tschüss bis
nach nach
wieder
Tschüss bis
später
blinkt l mal SMer dabfahren gesag da
eure Schul bald K da ist zu okay ja dann
muss wir vorne no parking okay dann
parkieren wir mal irgendwo anders
Achtung
schätz
morning die m elementary school hat die
besten Bewertungen in der
Umgebung morgen schon wird Lil Rose ganz
amerikanisch mit dem Bus zur med fahren
sie hat sch vom gangus sie zwei me
kennengelernt wo wie di in der Klasse
sind und dann hat sie schon gestrahlt
über beide J also ich glaub das G ganz
schnell bis sie D neue Freundin hat und
sie sich richtig wohl fühlt also ich
glaub ich hat gar kein bedenk
wirklich und dennch der Tag in einem
kleinen Drama
[Musik]
Enden also das war glaub ein W ich gern
wür da kommt Favorit vor ein Bäumchen
für die aufrichte aus dem eigenen
Wald so viel ja es gab zwei Varianten
der oder der groß aber mir muss immer
groß das heißt dieser darum wir jetzt da
schnz
zack 100 hekar ein Viertel des
Grundstücks der Schweizer ist bewaldet
die Tanne ist Symbol für Standhaftigkeit
und
Langlebigkeit es ist noch nicht Abend
und das letzte Teil der dachfürst ist
aufgesetzt oder
nicht
sehr sehr
schön
sch sch plat jeder Handgriff sitzt der
Bau ist
gelungen schön Platz ich kann jetzt
schon vorstellen wen
gerichtet
ich
[Musik]
so
ja der Tradition entsprechend schmückt
Elisabeth den
Richtbaum
ja mus noch zum
Sam ja
prima
[Musik]
Bravo
schön
[Musik]
am Rande des Dorfes GAL rayada haben die
beiden Auswanderer eine kleine Wohnung
gemietet meine
Uhr heute ist der große Tag ohne großes
Tamtam wollen sie ihr Restaurant das
brisas Delmar
eröffnen gut
geschlafen wir sind gut vorbereitet und
igich g alles aber nervös jetzt gerade
nicht vielleicht wenn man das Restaurant
fahr dann vielleicht schon
gest Brot hab nicht
organisiert kurzfristig noch
organisieren dass wir d starten ja sind
h Sache W einfach wieder mus danke zum
Betrieb
fahreen igenes Restaurant auf seiner
Lieblingsinsel während Jahren hatte er
im luzernischen schon ein Restaurant
geführt der Profi erkennt gute
Mitarbeiter Mariam ist einer
davon nur für Gabor ist alles
neu völlig unspektakulär nimmt der erste
Tag seinen Lauf aber jetzt hat wir offen
l keine 5 Minuten vergehen und schon
sind die ersten Gäste
da so
zweimal alle sind auf TR Marian der
erste erste Bestellung
zwei Salat vielleicht gut
wenn
WE
oder
bringink
oder mehr und mehr fühlt sich das
Lokal einmal komplett aufmachen einmal
nicht
warten ja sein der muss Schaum sein ne
warte warte wartete warte nein du darfst
nicht noch mal aufmachen weil da kommt
nur Schaum raus
dann
ja also ja mit dem Tablet hat er das
Gleichgewicht ne ist am Anfang natürlich
ein bisschen unsicher am ersten Tag aber
das ist auch normal aber ich denke so
innerhalb der ersten Woche da tanzt der
Ballet mit dem
Tablet corill führte das bras während
Jahren nun ist es ihre letzte
Saison
hier nur
so jetzt ist stressig ein bisschen weil
ich weiß nicht was wo ist und wie und
ja Schauer ne bitte Tisch ne tich
neun tich
neun soll ich helfen
ja alles
hellen her g
appeit für eine Kur
Pause ich habe für viele Leute gesagt
also mit der tabl meine
handld das mein erster Tag und alle habe
Verstand keine Problem alles
[Musik]
gut gegen Abend sind auch die Stammgäste
da W hat die
[Musik]
Spaghetti
wir haben sehr chaotisch gestartet am
Mittag es ist wir
war gemacht und das ist irgendwie ja es
irgendwie
funktioniert ja wir hab nicht so
wirklich schulig gemacht al für gab vor
allem und auch für mich meine mit dem
kassesystem und wo was ist Getränk und
so wie sie es gemacht h haben wir no
okay ja noch nicht genau wo sie alles
das Hus verursacht wo schon Bü merkt hat
sich schon beruhigt der gab weiß auch
schon viel wie es funktioniert mir haben
schon viel jetzt wieder optimiert undig
gemülich ST
ist sichtlich entspannt die Eröffnung
ist
geglückt im mobile home in Alligator
POINT wird heftig gearbeitet nur risu
ist für einmal gelangweilt die Schwester
hat heute einen großen Schritt in die
Welt gemacht sie aber muss bei den
Eltern
[Musik]
bleiben Immobilien kaufen renovieren
vermieten oder gar
weiterverkaufen das ist Melanie und
Marius Geschäftsmodell das Mob ist ihr
erstes Objekt das Sie schon bald
vermieten wollen Muser und dann
undgab no
problem die beiden sind handwerklich
begabt machen am liebsten alles
selbst und daät im früh und D noch die
silikonf die sind diese gar nicht gungen
im früh D wir d noch wegmachchen und neu
machen
Jaen immer
dazu nur viel Zeit bleibt ihnen nicht
denn alle die ganze Familie
wenn Lil Rose Schulschluss
[Musik]
hat wenn es
den ein
und lade vne wo sie noch nicht die sch
gegangen ist hab wir das schon pa
beobachtet und jem gesagt in der
Schlange ST ich ganz sicher und wart
[Musik]
die ich sch h
gefallen okay
ja
hi
got
ja
K sind ganz viel Kind in neer Klass ja
aber als ja
ja ein aufregender Tag doch die große
Überraschung kommt erst noch
[Musik]
Schink steef truppenkoch im Militär er
weiß wie man hungrige Männer verpflegt
das Kochbuch der Schweizer Armee hat er
auf
Mann neue
erfahrunghaupt nicht für so
so das ist schon no herusforder für mich
ja und ja wenn nicht wirklich topoch W
ich jetzt ja ist das schon WT einfach
gut machen D das sicher gen und dass es
auch no
schck die Faht bis zum nächsten
Supermarkt in dauert gut 30 minut
die Tage der Auswanderer sind während
der Bauarbeiten eng
[Musik]
getaktet für einmal hilft Steff nicht
beim Bau
mit er bereitet die Ferienwohnung für
die nächsten Gäste vor ich hab nicht z
zit und wenn ich so Züg mache D muss das
die
dasar und das G
so aber ich ma das nch gern und ich so
dies
unterstütze mus einach da vor
der
dann ist gut ja h schnell ich ma h ja
drei schubgaren voll mit Essen haben die
beiden Frauen
[Gelächter]
gekauftwoh ste diesamkeit in Island gest
mag er es eigentlich auch wenn etwas
läuft der Eventmanager hatte jahrelang
während der Freizeit Gäste
[Musik]
verwöhnt ja das ist schon so h hte viing
ist immer
schön und ich Paradies
im
und bis gest betreut üb Wochenend mit
Schneeschuh laufen und für sie kocht und
alles mögliche gemacht und gemacht und
Partys und ja mir immer mega Spaß
gemacht wenn gum sind und ich gern
vergest das ist für mich wirklich nicht
Problem aber gichzeitig bauen und
schaffe und Putz und n g richtige g
nicht Arbeiter ich halt ein Sch
rel wichtigste stim langweilig wird es
ihm bestimmt nicht sobald die Arbeiter
abreisen müssen Sie mit dem Innenausbau
[Musik]
loslegen auf Mallorca beginnt nun der
Alltag
otmas neuer Arbeitsweg gerade mal 10
Minuten rollend unter der spanischen
Sonne und das im
März die Eröffnung war auch finanziell
ein Erfolg gorina und
ich Abschluss sois g was haben wir
gemacht knapp 2000
€ so für er die
Tag diese zweif Frau hier gestern ja hat
gesagt oh wir möchten nicht nach Hause
gehen empflen ich würde das so machen
weil dann können die Leute so
laufen ihr Restaurant haben sie schon
früh im Jahr
eröffnet nach all den Auslagen brauchen
sie endlich
Einnahmen Herz ist
gut guten Morgen
morchen für Adina beginnt die siebte
Saison in bresas die gestandene
Kellnerin gibt utma
Sicherheit wo ist meine le
leermutter doch am zweiten Tag bleibt es
ruhig sehr
ruhig das heißt gar nichts die Leute
sind bei dem schönen Wetter unten ist
Markt es ist Markttag die Leute gehen
runter ins Dorf und auf dem Rückweg
kommen du dann hier Mittagessen Kaffee
trinken ab dann geht's eigentlich erst
los das ist Samstag so üblich vor der
Saison es geht eigentlich erst richtig
los Ende April Anfang Mai da kommen dann
die großen Gruppen viele Urlauber sind
[Musik]
da das erfahrene Personal nimmt es
gelassen diese Ruhe hat OTM der neu auf
der Insel ist
[Musik]
nicht Hof das bben so hoffe dass sich GL
Restaurant wieder füllt und d h
[Musik]
Hand doch so richtig will sich das
brisas am Tag nach der Eröffnung nicht
[Musik]
füllen
hallo
[Musik]
ein ereignisreicher Tag geht in Florida
zu
Ende mit großer Begeisterung ist Lil
Rose in ihr Abenteuer Schülerin einer
amerikanischen elementary school
gestartet doch bei den Hausaufgaben hat
sie große Mühe im
Rechnen in der Schulmappe finden die
Eltern den Grund
dafür sie ist in der zweite Klasse nicht
in der erste Klass
okay besprechen ich weiß es nicht wieso
das S die zwe
Klass die ich weiß nicht ja nicht
soach tricky find wie viel Klass
ja
KL und weiß nicht das so ganz so gute
Idee wenn ich da die Re aufgab dass sie
da jetzt gerade in die
zwelass mal das ist die einziggab oder
die Kleine ist in der falschen
Klasse für Lil Rose bricht eine Welt
[Musik]
zusammen
alles gut
ichb GLB das das das ist viel viel
verlang für Sie das ist echt viel mit
[Musik]
Reden nicht Schul mus nicht
mein extrem schnell und
gut sch da musst du
nicht das glau das musst nicht Kön dem
Alter morgen V sch
schnell und in der nächsten Folge von
auf und davon
überstürzen sich die
Ereignisse
Lil Rose darf endlich Schulbus fahren in
welche Klasse wird sie wohl
eingeteilt und chas expandieren ihr
neuestes Objekt ein Apartment direkt am
Meer Melanie treibt ihr eigenes Business
voran Hochzeiten am Strand
Ausrichten auf Mallorca nimmt die Saison
langsam Fahrt auf nur Gabor ist
allein hat eine heftige Krise und die
Schweiz zur du h keine Energie für
n für Gabor eine schwierige Situation
ich vermissste ih sehr wir war immer
zusammen diese Jahre lang wir war
überall
zusammen auf Island wird weiter hart
gearbeitet die Möbel für dietinuser sind
da die
Sindar und mit dem Schnee für die beiden
die Badesaison
[Musik]
[Applaus]
an
auf und davon präsentiert von Edelweiß